you're going on a journey  a journey through memory all you have to  do is follow my voice  [Music]  we're closed i know i'm sorry it's late  we have time for one more job  when the waters began to rise and war  broke out  [Music]  nostalgia became a way of life  there wasn't a lot to look forward to  some people began looking back  nothing is more addictive than the past  no no no no don't put me back  put me back i understand  she has moved on and you should too  people don't just  vanish to find where she'd gone i had to  know where she'd been  or she running from the past  or racing back towards it  how much  mercy where is he  [Music]  arson bribery murder people love their  secrets  don't go down this path stay here in  this  [Applause]  i've turned a life eye to plenty i have  to do this  [Music]  that machine of yours how close can you  get  before the illusion's broken  you're going on a journey all you have  to do is follow my  voice  you